Will you please join me in welcoming the
following tech style influencers to the
stage. Chloe Feldman Youtuber,
Aka Clo. We could tour
Darrin molden influencer
A. Darren wears it. Well,
I feel like I won
La La Chula Utuber Aka style by La.
Sure.
You Tuber John Phenomena I
told you I like and Brittany,
dk of Youtube.
Do you owe Britt x Brat to fashion?
We go.
There you go.
Hey guys, my name is John. You shy. I'm
going to be your moderator this evening.
Can you guys hear me in the
back? All right. Yeah. All
right, so I work at Youtube.
I work on our influencer
in creator marketing,
which basically means I have to watch a
ton of videos every day and get to know
what's going viral,
who our biggest stars from 1 million to
10 million subscribers and just have a
lot of fun with it.
I call it more of an obsession then a
profession and it's something that I never
imagined at your age that I'd be doing
and I just thought I'd start off before
we get to this amazing
panel that we have here.
Just to give a little bit more context
because I think tonight is all about
dress code.
It's all about fashion and tech,
but it's also all about paying it forward,
right?
And I think if you ask anybody on
this panel were, we'll get into it.
If you ask myself,
if you ask anybody behind you,
tonight's all about giving what we got
when we were in your shoes and nobody got
to this place alone.
And I want to ask you guys in high school,
how many of you guys know what you
want to be when you grow up? Really?
Okay. Awesome. So I want
to tell you two things.
There's no such thing as growing up.
No such thing.
In fact,
one of my favorite quotes is that growing
up is the moment you realize there's
no such thing. Tweet it, tweet it.
Sweet. It's good. Um,
and there's no such thing as
being one thing when you grow up
charge.
And lastly, the things that the people
that raised their hand, I applaud you.
You guys know more than
I ever did in your shoes,
but I guarantee you what you
want to be today will change.
And all I have to say is embrace it.
Your career will change a ton.
You will change a ton,
you'll get a lot of advice from mentors,
some of which you'll meet today,
others of which you'll meet in the most
unexpected ways on this journey we call
life.
And I just encourage you to go with it.
There's no wrong answers and there's a
place for everyone in this world and when
it comes to finding what's right for you.
Cool.
Awesome.
So let's get into our panel.
Let's give it up one more
time for them for coming out.
We got, we got two mikes. We got
to, all right. There you go. Cool.
So I thought I'd things off.
I'm always,
one of the questions I love asking
people is what are you most proud of in,
in your past? And what are you most
excited about in your presence?
So if you want to talk a
little bit about yourself,
but just mention of all the amazing
things you guys have done on this panel,
what's something you're most proud of
in your past and what's something that
you're excited about moving
forward in the future? Uh,
we'll start with you if you want to take
it or if you want to work on and we can
start over there. Start
all right. Right here.
Okay. So for me, I'm just going
to move on to bring the mic up.
So a little back story on me.
So I went to school for six years.
I did six years of college and graduated
with a doctorate of pharmacy degree. Um,
I graduated and I realized
that I hated it and you know,
and I also, um, you know, wanted
to tap into my creative side, um,
and kind of do what I
was passionate about.
And so we're going back to this question.
I'm proud of the fact that, um, you know,
I'm a pharmacist,
but I'm also proud of the head,
the courage enough to go after
what it is that I love to do. Um,
because like he said, you never grew
up. And so as 17 when you're told, okay,
it's time for you to pick a major in,
figure out what it is that you want
to do for the rest of your life,
you don't always know and you go into
something and you complete it and then
it's like, okay, I'm stuck.
But you're never stuck.
So you always have to know that
you have the power to, you know,
do whatever it is that you
put your mind to. So yes.
Okay.
I'm Chloe.
Um,
I think something I'm proud of myself
in my past is that I always have really
considered education a huge part
of what I do, even though I'm now,
I'm doing youtube full time
all throughout high school.
I've been doing youtube for seven years,
so all throughout high school,
like I really focused on learning,
talked about it in my videos,
talked about studying for the
act and applying to colleges.
And it's always been something I've
really pushed. So I think, you know,
no matter what you do, bringing education
into it is very important. And then, um,
just something I'm focusing on right
now is building a team and learning more
about the industry,
learning more about what message
I want to spread to everyone. So
beautiful.
Yeah.
Yup.
Give it up.
Hi, I'm ally. Um, I do youtube as well.
I think one of the things that I'm
most proud of is that I never gave up.
Uh, the journey getting to where
I'm at today was not easy. Uh,
but I love that it wasn't easy because
it made me who I am. Um, and yeah,
I mean it took me about four years,
uh,
and it was actually longer than that,
but once I started the committed
myself a team of about four years, um,
but it was an easy and a lot of the
things that you guys are going to be
passionate about it that you guys love,
you guys will find out that it's not easy.
So never ever give up on your dreams.
Always work hard,
believe in yourself.
And I always say that if
you put the time and effort,
you guys can make anything
happen. Um, and now I've, um,
now I have youtube,
I have three channels.
I also have a couple of businesses that
I've started with my husband and, um,
that's my future now, so
awesome. That's amazing. Yeah.
Okay.
What about you John? Yup.
She gets here. Me. Um, yeah,
so he's one of says
here's what I want to say.
This is actually pretty big for me. This
is, this is probably a big moment for me.
It's a milestone for me.
Um, I have a crazy story in,
in fashion. Um, I've been professionally
in fashion for the last 18 years. I just,
I just had my birthday,
so a,
believe it or not and me and my twin
brother just turned 40. Uh, wow. Yeah.
What Cameras Alex? We still
a good bro. Um, so, uh,
real quick, what I want to say is,
uh, I'm Filipino. Um, and uh, not,
not Hispanic, but in, in, in New York and
Florida, apparently I'm Puerto Rican, so,
but what I want to say is I'm Filipino
and your parents want you to be an
engineer or a nurse.
And so I met someone who worked for
Russell Simmons when I was 18 and he,
he designed clothing and never
knew that that could be a job,
that I can design streetwear.
And so I was like, that's crazy.
Now it's, this event is big for me
because I also teach in a high school.
Um, so shout to frontier and
[inaudible] hi everybody in Whittier.
Shout out to everybody there. But I
was telling my students, um, you know,
I always tell my students is like,
at the point when I started
to search my career,
I went backwards and I
said what I want to do.
So of course everyone wants
to be a baller, right?
So I want to make money and I wanted to
travel and I wanted something different.
So when I met a designer, I was like,
that's what I want to do. I took my folks,
I sat him down, I was 18 years old
and I was like, okay, don't freak out.
I'm going to drop out of
college and I don't worry,
I'm going to be coming apparel designer.
And they thought I was crazy.
My twin brother told me late here later
that they were like convinced John to go
back to school. So I did go to school.
I learned, I learned the classes,
all my graphic design programs
and everything. And uh, and it,
there's a reason on the panel today.
I was a director of the last
three companies I've been with.
I've managed a multiple multimillion
dollar clothing lines and uh, yeah,
so it's been a great story for your man.
Youtube channel helps people learn
how to lunch clothing lines. So, uh,
that's what I'm proud of.
Amazing.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah. Waiting for me. Oh my God.
I can leave on Wednesdays, right.
How are we getting panic attacks,
heart attacks? I'm here. Okay.
So my name is Brittany. I'm,
my channel is fashion related.
I teach people how to
make their own garments.
The outfit that I'm wearing right now,
I have a tutorial for,
so it's a skirt in a rap top. And, um,
I'm just really proud of how far
my youtube channel has grown,
especially being as sewing.
Um, that's like one of the
least search thing on youtube.
But, um, what I did to really
stand out on Youtube, um,
I used to intern for Michael Costello
and so I really started doing light
trending fashion. So, um, what
I realized is that was people,
was it putting out like gown tutorials.
So I will show people how to make your
own gown or how to make a wedding dress.
So the stuff that people would send me
from like all over the world with like
amazing.
So I do have a clothing line now and
I'm just really excited to see where it
takes off from now.
I love it.
So there's a few things in there
that I want to dive deep on.
First I want to say how awesome it is
that they really owned that question.
When somebody asks you like what
you're proud of and all of that,
you shouldn't shy away.
I love how you guys really talk about
all the hard work you've put in and,
and all the great things that
have come about that. John,
you mentioned something really
interesting. Then I think,
you know when you're in high school your
parents obviously have a huge influence
on you as they do throughout the rest of
your life and they always want the best
for you.
But I think it's so interesting growing
up in today's world where many of the
professions that will take aren't
even in existence right yet.
And I want to talk about each
of you to each of you guys.
How did you have that initial conversation
with your parents that you were going
to do what your heart desired and what
you're doing now and do you have any
advice for people in the audience
who may be thinking the same thing?
Like maybe your maybe your parents.
It doesn't have to be, Hey,
I'm dropping out of school.
It has to be more like, Hey,
I don't want to be a doctor or a lawyer.
I want to do something else.
Like do you have advice for people in
the audience that may be wanting to
produce a more,
more untraditional path as untraditional
becomes more of the norm in today's
world? Open? Anyone jump in, jump in.
I feel like obviously our parents love us.
So if they see that you're
truly passionate about
something and maybe in the
beginning they'll be very
shocked and they'll want,
maybe try to talk you out of it.
But when they see passion and dedication,
I mean I'm sure they're
going to support you,
but always start everything
with honesty and if it's,
if what they want is not what you want,
speak up.
Obviously it's your,
it's going to be your life.
It's going to be your time and you have
to make sure that whatever it is that
you do,
you're truly passionate about because
it's something that you're going to have
to dedicate a lot of time into it.
So,
okay.
Yeah. Beautifully said. Anybody
else? Any other thoughts?
Well, for me, luckily my
parents are really supportive.
I just remember I barely learned how
to sell like three or four years ago.
But I remember when I was three
years old, I made my mom, um,
a pair of shoes out of newspaper and
she wore those around the house. Ah,
yes. But she didn't realize,
she knew I love fashion,
but she didn't realize how,
how big it would be for me now
because I'm designing for, you know,
celebrities and I've been
working for Miko Costello.
I had to say that again.
I was going to say he did design dresses,
Beyonce, Lady Gaga. I could keep going.
But when you're really
passionate about something, um,
I just feel like you'll succeed in it.
And that's how I felt
like with my fashion.
That's beautiful.
And I think it also goes to say there's,
there's 7 billion people in the world.
Like small is big.
Like there's people who share
the same interest as you.
So if you're passionate about something,
then there's generally a
lot of people out there.
And one of the reasons I'm so proud to
work at youtube is that youtube gives
that access. So if you have an
idea, you can just upload, connect,
and who knows where that
will take you later. Um,
any other thoughts about the parent
conversation or advice? Uh, a couple
quick points. I should say
this, I did drop out of college,
but I went back later while
I was working full time.
I went back to school online so that
I could teach at a high school. Okay.
I'm not just, I'm so, I'm a huge fan.
My twin brother is actually an assistant
principal. Wow. Yeah. So it's all ma.
I'm a huge fan of education.
Um,
but what I want to say for what
I will say to my students, um,
so this is like a big glass
room for me is, you know,
the studies are showing that you're
going to work in a couple of different
industries by the time you guys
go to get your careers. Okay.
So that tells me a lot of things.
Um,
your degree is going to be about the
ability to go through tough finals and to
weather through it, but you also need
to have flexibility in terms of a,
having a skillset that you can then
put to something else. Right. And, and,
um, real quick, I just want
to save on that note of
attacking what you want to do.
Um, you brought up a good
point. You're going to do it,
you're going to be in the workplace
more than you're going to be with your
family, your wife, your
husband, your kids later.
So it got to be something
you're passionate about. And
in terms of attacking it,
like what I don't see is
like sometimes the hunger.
So you gotta be relentless about it.
Uh,
like quit story when I lived in San Diego,
I've found that 10 brands
that I wanted to work for,
and this was before Internet.
Okay. There was, there was,
there's the portion about coding
and everything. So when I speak,
I'll say we use the term computer nerd
when I was in high school and then it
gets, it gets just like this, it gets
nothing. Right? But before it was, we can,
I can afford a computer.
I mean, it was expensive.
Now everybody got it on their phone.
But you gotta be relentless about,
about really attacking it.
So I found 10 brands I researched,
I went to them and I said, hey,
I'm going to be a designer.
I'm not one right now and I will drive
from San Diego to get you a coffee.
And then when they said no,
I would come back and I have 10 questions.
How did you get this job?
What's the best thing about your job?
What sucks about it? What's a
tough month? What's a good one?
What's a high and low? Those
sort of things. So a couple
pieces of advice there,
but that's the kind of mind state
that I have when I attack it.
And so for this 18 year career,
I've done a little bit of styling on music
videos. I was doing, uh, you know, uh,
I was a fashion editor for a little bit,
but it's all been around brands,
but I use the same skillset on
to the next kind of venture.
And you guys should kind of have
that too when attacking your career.
That's amazing.
Wow.
Yeah.
Any other thoughts on the parent?
Yup.
Yeah, I definitely agree with that.
You're saying like anything you,
you guys want to do, like if you
want it bad enough, you can do it.
And I think that's how it was
with my youtube and still is like,
I literally live, breathe youtube.
I'm posting videos every day,
sometimes twice a day, and it's like
taken over my life. But I love it so much.
And I was in school, I went
to Ucla, my dad is really,
really big on education and has
always been like, it's his main thing.
But he saw how passionate I was about
what I was doing and how successful I was
becoming. And I think, you know, if you,
if you have that drive for something and
maybe it's not exactly like what your
parents thank you,
you're going to do it.
I think I'm just going for
like what your heart is saying.
Yeah.
That's beautifully said.
I would say to just do your research
and present them with their research and
just kind of like the same reason that
you want to do it and the vision that you
have for just presented
to them. Um, and you know,
research it and show them somebody
that's successful at it already. Um,
and that will be a good way. And
then also just always, you know,
come up with a plan. So maybe it is that
you do end up having to go to college.
Um, and for, you know,
something that maybe more career
driven and now your passion,
well then maybe your plan is that you'll
use that career to fuel your passion or
to fund your passion. So
it's about like, you know,
having a plan as long as you have
a plane and you know exactly,
you know where you want to go at the end.
I think that's most important.
That's amazing.
I think a lot of you guys talked about
mentorship and like looping in older
people and I think there's a quote that's,
it's great to learn from your mistake,
but it's even better to learn
from somebody else's. Right.
And that's what mentorship gives you. You
can tweet that one out too. Um, and I,
so I want to talk about, you know,
a lot of people talk about hustle.
Like a lot of people say go out
there, go hard. Like, yeah, eat,
sleep and drink your work. You guys
have all done it. I think that the,
the thing that would make
it really specific and add
a lot of color to it is if
you guys could tell maybe
a story of something like
now some of you got millions
of subscribers, you're reaching so many
people every day. Let's rewind back.
Like what's the story of, you know,
a moment where something click,
you did something, you put in the
work that other people didn't.
I think the more specific we get here,
it will really add a lot of color to
what you have to do to get here because
it's more than just saying nice
things is actually doing them.
And you guys have all
done it. Go ahead. Yeah.
Um,
so before Youtube I actually went to film,
which is a fashion school.
I've loved fashion since
I was in high school. Um,
and I see when I discovered youtube,
I actually discovered it because my
husband was like, oh, there's this video.
I didn't even know what youtube was,
but I went on youtube and then some
high trickled across a beauty video.
It was a haul video.
And I became,
I instantly became fascinated with the
fact that somebody can actually share the
things that they were buying.
But then I always see things
from a business perspective
at back then, uh, the,
the video that I was watching, I think
it had about 20,000 views and I said,
oh my Gosh, if 20,000 people saw
this video of her hall video,
then if 1% of these people,
actually,
if I had a website and 20,000 people
can watch the stuff that I saw on my
website and 1% would go on my website,
then that's like so many people
that can buy stuff for my website.
So I always saw it from a
business perspective. So then I,
my husband bought me a computer and I
started filming my videos at home and
obviously I thought it was going
to be like an instant sensation,
but nobody was watching my videos and
I would speak, I was very frustrated.
I did it for about two years and I had
a thousand subscribers and I would stay
up till like three,
four in the morning and I would Google.
How can I get more views on my videos?
What hashtags should I use on my videos
or what tags should I put on my videos?
I would not sleep because I wanted this
so bad and I had to figure out a way to
do it.
And despite the fact that nobody was
watching my videos and people would laugh
at me for still filming
and uploading and editing,
I was still doing it because it was
something that I truly, truly loved. Um,
fast forward about three years after that,
uh, my brother said, you know, they do,
they make these videos in Spanish.
And the first thing I did was I went into,
into youtube and I typed
in what's in my bag.
That was one of the big
popular videos back then.
It was about a hundred
thousand videos came up.
And then I typed in [inaudible],
which is the same exact thing,
but in Spanish and it was about
300 videos and I speak Spanish.
So then I thought to myself,
this market has not been tapped into.
So I started uploading videos in Spanish.
I didn't give up.
I didn't give up on the fact
that I'm uploading, I'm applying.
I was trying to figure out
ways on how I can get in there.
My Youtube channel now has over,
it has 1.3 million subscribers.
If you would have,
if you guys would have told me that I was
going to have a, a channel that big, um,
you know, four or five years ago,
I would have been like, yeah,
I'm dreaming about it,
but I don't think I'm actually going to
ever get there because no one's watching
my stuff. So, um, I don't even
remember what the question was.
But if you guys the story of Hustle,
yes,
I did not sleep trying to figure out how
I can make this happen because I truly
wanted it. And I guess more of the
story is if you guys want something,
even if you know, it doesn't seem
like it's going to happen for you,
I promise if you guys keep working at it,
you eat, breathe, sleep, your passion,
you guys will make so
[inaudible]
any other stories?
Well, for me, before Youtube I was working
being at Disneyland. Yeah. Yeah.
The happiest place on
earth. Oh, they say. Um,
but no. Um, I just remember, uh,
when I started working at Disneyland,
I started,
yeah,
my youtube channel.
But I will always find myself sketching
out outfits at the register and I'm just
like,
you know, there'll be a time to clock
out and I'll be like, all right.
And then I'm scrubbing the gutters.
I'm just like, why am I doing this?
It's not fun.
So what I did was I took my last paycheck
and that's when I started my business.
And so it kind of launched from there.
And then I took a percentage of that
their last paycheck and then I used it for
my youtube to invest in, you
know, better equipment material.
And so from there everything
seems to work out for me.
But Youtube definitely
takes a lot of hard work,
a lot of hard work. Um, I find
myself sewing at five in the morning,
but it's so fun.
Oh my God.
Like I'm sowing and it just like,
it doesn't feel like work.
I mean it's fine. So basically what
I'm trying to say is if you're,
you have a passion about something,
definitely go and do it because that's
like the best thing you could do.
Absolutely.
And if I get build on,
I think that you touched on
something very important,
which is what do you
guys procrastinate with?
Cause that's probably what
you're passionate about. Right?
But you spend the free time, I will do
some audience Q and a after this. Yep. So,
so you, you like, there's a lot of
things that yeah, like growing up,
people tell you to do a lot of things,
especially when you're at your age. Right?
But the thing that you should probably
be doing is what you're most passionate
about. If you find yourself coding
until the wee hours of the night,
he should probably be a coder.
You know,
don't fight your instincts like
there's a place for everyone.
And just like you did,
like if you have a job and like you,
at some point you will have to find a way
to make ends meet, find inbetween work.
But you know,
if you find yourself doing that in
your free time and procrastinating,
then that's probably what you should be
doing as a profession. And there's a way,
like,
we're lucky.
So we are so lucky to live in this day
and age where you could turn that into
something that has an audience and
reach people all around the world. Um,
I think I also want to point out
from your story, uh, uh, the,
the words overnight success, that's a
total oxymoron, right? That does that.
There's no such a thing.
It takes years to be an overnight success
and that's how people perceive you. Um,
so I see it [inaudible] part
of my day job. You know,
like a lot of people start on youtube.
They're very excited,
but they don't have the dedication
and alive. You guys all did.
It sounds like we'll
open it to the audience.
I want to give you guys a final word
before we opened it up to questions.
Is there anything that you
guys want to talk about?
Like things that you want
to people to know about?
I want to continue the conversation.
If you want to give your,
your Twitter handles or your Instagram
or your youtube channels, anything that,
uh, is, is a good way to keep
in touch with you. Awesome.
Well you guys getting to follow me
on Instagram. Brick eggs, bread to
burdick's Brat too. I think it's on the
and so on though. Yeah, it's all on there.
Um,
and also I heard a host workshops and
classes at Youtube every once a month,
so you guys can check that out
on you to space website. Sorry,
can
I share a little bit on the last port?
Absolutely. Go ahead. Sorry. I just,
I just have to say no need to
apologize. Um, for me. Okay.
So let me tell you all of this.
I have a fraction of the
number of subscribers of, of
these beautiful ladies on,
on the panel and, um, and but yes,
but look out for the collab.
They're all going to collab with John
Phenom at some point. Um, hope. All right.
But uh, here's what I want to say is, uh,
I'm the co I was the guy
where people would say, hell,
my friend designs clothing.
And so I get a random call from so and
so and I'd be, they'd be like, Hey,
I'm so and so's friend and I'm trying to
start a clothing line. I'm like, okay,
cool. Uh, what do you need to know?
So when I started my youtube channel,
I just put up 20 videos of what I would
always tell people to do in terms of
starting a brand. And I was,
it was funny cause I was like,
no one's ever going to watch this.
I get like a hundred views in
like all month or something. So,
but I would say go to
this youtube channel.
And when I stepped away
from it for a while,
it came back and there was
like a thousand subscribers.
So saw people wanted the information.
And so now I'll do a lot of consulting
and they'll come from my base of people
looking for the information.
So for me that,
that's where something kind of clicked
and I realized I could actually offer
value. Um, uh, but yeah, so just
want to share that and for me,
if you just Google oh wow. I just said
if you Google at Google, that is crazy.
That's crazy. That's crazy. Um,
you can Google and you'll find,
you'll find me. And then my,
my youtube channel is
Ford Slash John Fino.
Thanks Jack.
Any other thoughts before we open it up?
Are the things you guys want to say?
I think I just want to leave you
guys with this last little bit.
With social media, we are, you know,
watching each other and oftentimes we'll
start to compare ourselves to, you know,
people that we see and they may
inspire us and we'll say, oh, you know,
like I want to do what they do.
I want to be like them,
but like I would never be able to do that.
You have to always remember that
they had a story and they had a,
they were in the same position
that you were at one point,
but they had to make the decision
and have courage enough to,
to go after what they want it
to do and believe in themselves.
So a lot of times with social media,
you have to shut it off in a sense
that you have to look at yourself as an
individual and know that you are fully
capable of doing what they had to do.
Um, it's not gonna be easy.
It wasn't easy for them. Um,
they have probably many
sleepless nights and you know,
probably want it to give up,
but you always have to be persistent and
always know that you can do whatever it
is that you want to do.
So,
and also note social media people
are always only put in there.
You know what they want to
show you. They're not showing
you the back end of it.
They're not showing you the late
nights when you're, you know,
up at five in the morning sewing
or like when you're, you know,
editing your videos so you don't see that.
But you see that amazing
picture or that amazing video.
There's always work,
work that's behind it is never easy,
but you can do it.
Yeah.
Any other thoughts guys? Some
series wisdom he dropped, right?
Oh and follow me on Instagram.
Ed. Darren, where is it?
Well and Dan was the world.com is my blog,
so it makes sure you take me out.
Boom. Nice. Nice. Any other
thoughts before we open it up?
I'll plug my socials.
Um, yeah, so my Twitter,
Instagram,
everything's at Chloe couture tour and
then I started a clothing line last year
called glow by Clegg, a tour. So I'm,
that's all on [inaudible] dot com
if you guys want to check that out.
Cool. Awesome. Awesome.
I think we have a boxed,
a pass around for questions. Two
questions. Maybe we will do it.
One from this side. One from
that side. Yup. Do you want
to stand up? Say Your name,
introduce yourself?
I have Khalila I'm from Gala
Girls Academic Leadership Academy.
Oh,
right.
Give it up for her,
for asking the first question.
That's amazing.
That takes courage.
And, um, I just had a
question. Like what would say,
like what would you say your main focus
was when you were like going towards
your goal?
Great question.
Think about that one.
Uh, so for me, I'm obviously, I met
this Guy Alioscha who was a designer.
So I would write it everywhere.
I would just tell everybody I'll put out
in the atmosphere that I am a designer.
So I was, I was on my way to becoming a
designer and I was real serious about it.
I didn't breathe until I was,
I became an apparel designer.
Then after that it was other things,
creative director and all
of that sort of thing.
Uh, my main focus, uh,
well when I started you to my
main focus was always a business.
I always knew that I wanted
to have my own business. Um,
so I always made sure to keep that
in mind and whatever, whatever I did.
So I was always figuring out a way how
I can leverage what I had and actually
turn it into a business. So always
owning my own company was my goal.
Amazing.
I think for me,
um,
something that's always been my focus
and always will be my focus is getting
better.
And that's like at first it was getting
better with makeup and then getting
better with my video quality and now
it's just getting better as a person and
learning how to convey that and
spread the message to you guys.
Amazing.
I think a lot of them sounds
when we started with the goal,
we think of the end result and you have
to use that as fuel to get you there.
Cause you know there's the hard
work in between. But also, you know,
remember that their shining moment that
you see yourself in or whatever it is
that that goal is at the end. How you see
yourself remember that and use that as,
as Ammo to just, you know,
really work hard and go after it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And there's actually a lot of studies
that show if you visualize yourself
attaining the goal,
you're much more likely to get it.
So if you begin with the end in mind,
you'll be ahead.
Yeah. And for me, um,
when I started youtube,
it was definitely also to be a
better designer. Am a lot of,
I was, I was actually going
to school for fashion design,
but I felt like I wasn't learning enough.
So that's when I kind of took a break
from school and just started teaching
myself techniques and then that's when
I Brung it to you too. And so, um, yeah,
it w two is all about me teaching
people from all over the world.
And I know a lot of you
guys are in high schools,
so I know prom season we'll
be coming up for you guys.
So if you want to learn how
to make yes right there,
if you're going to learn how to make
your own prom dress and the guys,
I have clothes for you guys to my channel.
I'm just saying
I love it. Any other thoughts
before we go to the next question?
I agree a lot on the visualizing thing.
I've,
I've always visualized every single
goal through this entire process.
Like my first thing was that I really
wanted to get to 100 subscribers and
everyone doubted me and laughed at
me and said I wasn't going to do it.
But I knew in the back of my head like
I just was picturing myself with the a
hundred subscribers. I already went out
and bought, I was going to do a giveaway.
I like bought it before I even got them.
So just really like putting yourself
in that place and like acting like you
already have it is a big key to success.
Amazing. Great Advice. Thanks. Very
question. Ah, we'll do one more.
Cool.
Right here. Oh, we okay.
Go. Do you want to stand up? Introducers
like give it up for it hasn't quite
wait to go. What's your
name? What's your question?
My name is honey Tokyo Masha Gay.
I,
I'm from Alliance Bloomfield high school.
And my question is what really
inspires you to do this for you?
Ooh,
great question.
Sometimes it's when you figure
out what you don't want to do,
that in spa will lead you to what it
is that you do want to do. So for me,
you know, graduating in, you know,
becoming a pharmacist and then,
you know, at work I was bored. I
was, you know, I was like, mmm,
this is boring. You know, it's
good money but it's boring.
So sometimes it's what you don't want to
do when you're in that place where you
know, okay, I don't want to
be here. That's what you know,
drives you or gives you the idea or
stirs you up enough to say, okay,
what is it that I do want to do?
That's amazing.
All high school students,
high school students should hear what you
just said. That's amazing. It's so true.
What do you guys think
about that question? What
inspires you? What's your why?
MMM, well for me, um, like I said,
I always had a passion for fashion.
Um, I definitely feel like if you
put anything out on social media,
definitely do something that you enjoy
and don't do it because it's trending or
is the next popular thing. But, um,
I just really enjoy doing what I do is
like just waking up every day sewing,
making videos for youtube and seeing
all the work that people send to me from
all over the world. He
just, I really enjoy it.
Uh, w what I want to say for you guys
individually when you guys are thinking,
because everybody's thinking
about how does this apply to me?
So it's once you guys go on your journey
and it doesn't matter what age you are,
you know, like I had a friend
told me the other day, he's like,
he's 35 and he's like, I hate my job.
I don't want to do this. Help me John.
So it's the same thing that I
would tell like a 16 year old kid.
You have to get familiar with the
things that you love and don't love,
just like you were saying.
And then when you get on your journey,
like you might go into one
job and figure out, wow,
I don't like this or I
don't like this situation.
Maybe if you pivot it and change it,
um,
there's another thing
that that you'll love.
That's why I've tried so
many different things.
Like I probably have 10
versions of my resume,
but it all kind of culminates
with fashion and Oh,
another thing that I'll always tell people
is when you do find what you want to
do,
um,
find the best mentor possible
who's doing it. Okay.
Like there's a reason why someone is
first in their field and someone is 226th
at the same industry, the same job. Right.
Like I would pay money for to intern with
someone who's number one or maybe they
have a huge ego and I don't like that.
So I go with number six.
Do you see what I'm saying?
Because at the end of that,
I don't want to compromise, you know, I
don't want to devil wears Prada situation,
wouldn't me? Cause that wouldn't, that
movie wouldn't end like that for me.
Where's the camera for real? It would
end like that. I'm Filipino for real. So,
um,
what what I'm saying saying for
you guys is find that best mentor.
Learn everything you can
from them because when they,
their psychology is different.
When they wake up and when she's doing
her youtube, she has 3.2 million,
y'all 3.2 million subs don't sleep on it.
So when she wakes up in the morning,
her psychology is different than someone
who has way less subs in that the
designer, architect, whatever
it is you guys, realtor,
whatever you guys want to be,
there's someone who has a psychology
and if you success leaves clues.
So if you grab some of those clues,
it will expedite your career
by decades and by money.
Y'all tons of money. So like, and
that's not necessarily the, the,
the push for it. Okay. It's about
being happy with your life, right?
Because studies show at about 80 90 grand.
You can kind of get everything you want
in your life. So you guys are young.
You'll be like, I want to be rich,
I want to be a baller. You know?
But it's in time. You'll see, but
it's about finding a mentor and then,
and then getting the,
getting the clues of success from
them to really your career up.
Great.
I think we're going to start wrapping up,
unless you guys have any
quick thoughts to drop in.
Any quick thoughts before we wrap up?
Cool. Um, I want to say thanks so much
for coming out and the ending note,
I want to say this is not
the end of the conversation.
It's very much at the beginning.
Uh, look us up on your program.
Add us on social media, come
up to us after this, uh,
event we want to talk to you,
we want to help you with
while I'm paid forward,
I want to give it up one more time
for our, our amazing panelists.